100万円曲1本ねー
100万円近くの1本目が決まりました記念すべき第1本目があの
も知ってる方もいると思うんですけどもあの僕がですねばなんだめちゃくちゃ買って
余ったとっきーに手伝ってくれたどこての園長さんがいましてその方がですね
ちょっと今あるプロジェクトをやっておりまして金係数を s 外来種収容巨大いて
建設プロジェクトという奴が今やって
おります園長さんがでいきの作ろうとしております初類の動物園なんですけどもう
ちょっと問題が今起こってますってそもそも外来種って何かっていう話です外来種って
いうと日本にもともといない動物のことを外来種と言います普通の各段主では外来じゃ
ないんですけど
コーカサスオオカブトとかヘラクレスオオカブトとか日本に田舎布団ですよあれ
もうすでに外来種でございます外来種の動物を飼う人結構いるんですよね日本に住んで
ないとか下とか
蛇とか神とか買う方は結構大勢いらっしゃってますってその動物たちが最近捨てられ
たり
発揮されたりしていますそれが今人大杉で社会問題になっていますと園長さんの経営し
ているイズっていう動物園なんですけども買えなくなっ
誰かえ買うことはいろんな理由であるんですよ店均じゃない理由の時もある家庭の事情
とかで何か病気になったり色々あって飼えなくなってしまったりしたから大小のペット
が入ってローブ前だとその甲斐なくなった外来種を預かったりそ閉じたりしている
みたいです気取りですねでもちろんの外資が日本にパーって例えば何か扱い
めちゃくちゃ強いが囲碁部の生き物が今日本にバーって話されると
そいつが日本の動物尾根の抗議したり殺したりしちゃって停滞系に影響を及ぼすかも
しれないっていう結構でかい問題なんです他の生き物が死んじゃうかもしれない
そこで園長さんが捨てられたり野に放たれるぐらいだったらすべて式取りますという
ことで来週の動物を入れを引きつったりしてるんですけどもうそれがもう多すぎて
キャパシティオーバースキットル場所がないっていう所
非常に今になってしまっておりますそこでまぁ特に緊急を要しているのが日目
亀の居場所が流れないから来てくれたカメさんたちの居場所がないのでマジで多い
らしいですね ok 数が千匹以上の亀がいるみたいです
それ選手目たらなかなかきついスはそこで園長さんはもうどうすることもできない神
さらに収容するためにイマサの巨大な息を作るプロジェクトが進んでいますあの
もちろん作るだけもそうなんですけど作ってあったの維持費とかね色々な事を含めると
とてもづらいんですけどすごい金額が必要なんですよそこで100万円の最初の使い道
は
a このプロジェクトに100万円を
投資させていただくということにしましたあの本当に日目も作りたいいるし何より僕は
の延長さにとてもお世話になってるんで少しでも何か手伝いができないかな
ポセアは約ま
池で遊べねーからプロとれねーかなとか思ってまあまあのいろんなことを含めて日目の
ために池たびに演者さんのために地球のために行ってもいいのかなって思いました
100万円という金額がすぐぴったりだったんですけどこれプロジェクトでお金を集め
てますクラウドファンディングみたいな皆がもうこれ支援できまして
申込金額が3,000円5,000円10,000円
3万円5万円10万円30万円100万円このどれかの金額うれしいができて
100万円っていう支援の枠が1人しかなくてその一口を
私いただきまして100枚で僕が支援したやつにはその池の名前を決めるという特典が
付いておりますってことは俺の意見
僕だけっていうわけ
たんですけど僕が新しくできる神さん達の生きる名前を付けるという状態でございます
でまだ家建設中なんですけどどんな場所がちょっと見てみましょう
ガー
この立ち位置
グレーねっ左より
音響2番目 the voodoo
カメラはこれは多分いっ今延長リーダー見ちゃったら
がっね
多いですね
ええええええ
ここらへんの名著 t 15m
[音楽]
ん
でその写メの凶
ここらへんまでその社分のね
[音楽]
なるほどだろうぞ
ここらへんも全部
一杯やもう広いですねー
[音楽]
栗裏せっさん波動
近いうっせ草子供何なんでああ
とって演じるあの調整してるんだけどねできるだけ早く寝暖かくなった頃には作りたい
んだねそうですねえ月もできて大穴ほど曲まで取れているので
道から a
4月5月には4
[音楽]
できればいいかなければいいかなとなるほどなるほどおかげでおかげさまで家さんの
ほうがいい
[音楽]
ブーバーよろしくお願いしまーす
国際支援おいでよ
あの
思っている何もなかったですしまだまだ開発途中ですからというか誰まで作りたいと
いう話だったねちょっと夏ごろ楽しみでございます中計700万円企画まだまだあるん
ですけどいろんなを進めてますけど
花のもやるし補充何かのために使ったりもするし俺のために使ったりもするし
まあいろんな使い道を考えているのでぜひお楽しみに
でほんと楽しみですね
なんか泳いで意味ではずだったんでちょっと池長いは実はですねまだ決まってないん
ですけど行けが完成近づいたらまたをするんですよと思いますというわけでこれで少し
でもカメさんたちが
救えればいいなと思っておりますでこの巨大池建設プロジェクトのご支援
3月の18日まで行っておりますその日本にいるほかの野生の動物の異物を
空ことにもつながりますのでぜひ皆さんのご支援をお待ちしております
めっちゃ戦でみたいなちょっとでもいいので皆さんのご協力を待つしておりますだけで
100万円企画
どんどん進んでいってますのでお楽しみに
[音楽]
me
ni
バッハ